the Joe Rogan experience yeah I had
Marian Smith from this PMO communism on
my show and since my focus in North
Korea I wasn't that much folks in China
and Hugh and we all think in the West
that you know China's gotten so much
better than it was which is true but he
goes it's still really really really bad
and one of the big I think fair
criticisms with the corporate press is
how much they're focused on Putin and
Russia and it's like you calling him a
dictator the [ __ ] they're pulling in
China is an order of magnitude worse and
something that they're doing now they
stole from North Korea North Korea has a
something called song bun and everyone
Hong bun s Ong be when someone everyone
in North Korea got interviewed and there
were several iterations of this and you
got a score based on your family so if
you our family was born in South Korea
or a priest or landowner that's a low
score if you your grandfather fought
with the great leader Kim il-sung that's
a high score it's divided into favored
class wavering and hostile and there's
like 51 subcategories and this
determines everything about your life
where you live where you go to college
and China is now starting to do this
they're trying to implement a social
credit system based on your loyalty to
the government which will allow things
like lead in the country and all sorts
of other opportunities and that's scary
scary stuff and that's what needs to be
I think covered much more in the West
the problem with that is it becomes like
a game and people are gonna want to have
a really high school of course that's a
big people are so weird when it comes to
scores and games but we get so you have
to have a high score or else you're not
getting food that's our job right right
right yeah but it's also like people
covet it oh but they don't tell your
score oh geez you have to intimate it oh
yeah it's scary oh yeah yeah so you got
it fly right and so you're always
nervous Europe that's what they want
you're always nervous it's not a
transparency self-censoring as well yes
right it forces a system of self
censoring like Twitter yes are you
saying that Twitter's like China did you
say that Twitter's like communist in
those words yes
no we got a ways to go for communism but
some of the techniques they use are very
disturbingly totalitarian yes
disturbingly so the other thing is yes
they are private company it's funny how
the left is like as soon as you
criticize Twitter there
company thing to do they want but any
other private company whatever a private
company can be criticized and if you
know you're perfectly appropriate in a
free market to say what you're doing is
screwed up and give us answers or we're
gonna use another company I think when I
talk to Jack about this one of the
things that he was saying is that
they're considering an open Twitter like
they're gonna have Twitter where it's
like a safe neighborhood and Twitter
where it's like the Wild West
okay and I said please do that yeah I
said please do that